Christopher Riley, Screenwriter, Author,
and Instructor: Somebody has said that
the job of the artist is to see and
then to show others what they've seen.
Film Courage: Can we talk about moments
that heal or repair a character?
Christopher: I love moments in film where there
is restoration of some kind that happens in a
way that seems believable, that doesn't seem
shangri-la. I think about the film Blood Diamond
in this regard. There's really two
stories that happen in Blood Diamond.
We have the story of a South African diamond
merchant played by Leonardo DiCaprio who is
trafficking in these blood diamonds (I think
this the movie takes place in Sierra Leone)
and so he's on the hunt for this giant diamond
that he's heard has been found out in the
mines that are run by the rebel military and the
rebel military conscripts boys as child soldiers
both to fight for them but also to work in these
mines. The other main character is played by
Djimon Hounsou and he's the dad of a boy who has
been abducted and taken away from his village
made to be a soldier who commits atrocities
so this young boy 10 years old maybe
has been made to do horrible things and his
dad is determined to find his son and somehow
bring him back to the family and as he's
doing that he gets forced into working
digging for diamonds for the people who stole his
son from him and he finds this massive diamond
and he buries it out away from the
camp and continues looking for his son
Leonardo DiCaprio finds out Djimon
Hounsou's got this massive diamond hidden
and at gunpoint takes him to dig up
this diamond and just as they're digging
for this diamond chime and Hounsou's son
shows up and is holding a gun on both men
Leonardo DiCaprio alerts Djimon Hounsou's who's
digging for the diamond that his son is here
and so this father turns to his son who now turns
the gun to him and is calling out the sons calling
out for help and Djimon Hounsou's says you're
not one of them you're my son and i'm your father
your mother waits for you your sister waits
for you the wild dog who listens to no one
waits for you at home you're not a bad boy I
know they made you do bad things but you are
going to come home to be me and be my son again
and I’m going to love you and in the midst of this
the father is walking toward his son walking
toward the barrel of the gun and the son
begins to cry and slowly lowers the gun and
allows himself to be embraced by his father
that is written directed and acted
in a way that you believe that
that is a moment of restoration and recovery
that maybe shouldn't even be possible
that it would be that you could recover a child
who has been put through those experiences
the film presents it with a kind
of emotional believability that
certainly represents a defining
moment for that boy and his father
that is going to be the pivot point
certainly this kid's going to need
probably lots of therapy and lots of love
over lots of years to completely emerge from
that awful darkness but in that moment you
believe that there is real hope and that
this moment represents a before and after that
they will look back 10 years from now and see
that is the moment that the healing began that the
restoration began and that love began to eclipse
hate in the life of this boy I think healing's
like that it doesn't usually come in a moment
usually it comes a little bit at a time but it it
has a beginning and as storytellers as filmmakers
we have the capacity to aim the camera aim the
attention of the audience at even the minutest
movements so that we are able to perceive
the moment when a process of healing begins
and actually allow the audience to to
see feel and appreciate what's happened
in a way that if we were on stage
and we were looking at the proscenium
like you'd miss it you'd never know what was
happening we we have the capacity to to zoom in
on these massively significant movements
of character that are almost imperceptible
somebody has said that the job of the artist is
to see and then to show others what they've seen
and for me this is an example of that
of looking closely enough to see this
monumental thing that's happening in this tiny
little frame and blow that up so that we see it
we understand it we we appreciate its meaning
and we feel it and it seems that combination of
meaning and emotion are another of the things
that we we just really crave from our stories
just out of curiosity what was the Leonardo
DiCaprio character doing during that moment he was
he was standing and watching he
had he had his assault rifle and
I think he was ready to shoot the boy
if he felt he needed to but he was he
was also witness he was bearing
witness to this miracle moment
so even I haven't seen the film but because
his intentions sounds like they were not that
honorable either okay so he but he's seeing
this and do you see a little bit of change
in that character at all yes yeah after that he
he discovers that actually he's been shot in the
fire fight that happened just before this scene
he ends up really sacrificing himself to help
father and son escape so yeah it does actually
transform him to have witnessed this moment.